this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Evan for that introduction as
he said I'm Justin Wilkerson I'm a
third-year PhD with Larry smart so I
moved to Geneva about a year ago and so
that's why some of you may not even
recognize me I've been up in Geneva so
hopefully by the end of this talk you'll
have some idea of what I've been up to
have actually been doing things up there
but I'm going to talk to about one
component of my research which is using
this common parent f1 hybrid mapping
population basically to find resistance
so I know Brennan gave a talk last week
on trouble but I wanted to give sort of
an update so trouble is a very diverse
or Salix is a very diverse genus there's
roughly 300 species they come in tree
and shrub form a lot of different ploidy
ranges and a lot of them hybridize
within within each other so it's there's
a lot of diversity to play with and it's
really interesting sometimes it has a
variety of uses between biomass grow and
for bioenergy for remediation because it
can grow on soils that are typically
unsuitable for other crops
it's very Hardy and also just as
physical barriers like privacy fences or
alongside roadways it's like snow snow
blots it is dioecious and highly
heterozygous we have male and female
plants which makes breeding interesting
and willow that has grown in a short in
a for biomass is grown in a short
rotation copper system so this means we
plant cuttings they're cut back after
one year and then they are harvested for
chips every two to three years
afterwards so these plants can stay in
the field for 20 plus years before
they're switched down so you can imagine
kind of in this picture here it's very
dense kind of planning structure and so
diseases and insects can really thrive
and take hold in these kind of
situations and so the most damaging of
them being willow leaf rest of a
relative of the talk that we just heard
from tight so it can lead to complete
defoliation in a year and it can result
up to a 50 percent total yield reduction
it is also macrocyclic in hetero asia so
this means that we'll go through all
five of the spore stages that we heard
about before
and requires an alternate host to
complete them so the alternate host for
the figure I have here would be the
balsam first so it's more of a tree rest
like I said it's got that potential for
sexual recombination each year so you
can imagine when you've got willow
that's in the field for 20-plus years
that may have been resistant to rest
when you planted it you have something
that's sexually recombining every year
so that resistance is probably not gonna
be there after a few years of sexual
recombination and it is described by
mainly by these yellow to orange holes
that are on the underside of the leaf
and this is how we used to phenotype
severity based on the percent coverage
of a leaf by using these sports so
because it is so complicated there's a
lot of diversity within Melara but like
I said there's a lot of diversity within
Salix we wanted to try and kind of use
that diversity in Salix to identify
resistance genes that can be sort of
pyramid in to make sure plantings in
that SRC system so typically they're
grown in monoculture but if you the best
form of management the most effective is
to make sure plant with different levels
of resistance so obviously we need to
know about those resistances before we
can advise what kind of mixtures need to
be planted and so two different mapping
populations were constructed to get more
information on the shrub willow so the
first one is a Salix purpurea f2
population that kind of takes center
stage and other aspects of my research
but for the time being I'm going to talk
about the other eight families that are
surrounding it so these eight families
comprise the common parent what we call
for short just the common parent mapping
population so we utilize the naturalized
Salix purpurea which is the nine four
six and nine four oh one is these purple
boxes so four families share it's my
instinct to move in my hand but I'm
gonna do this
so four of these families share nine
four oh six as the common female parent
and the other four will use nine four oh
one as the common male parent we say
like such a wince s in women Alice
having a reciprocal cross with Enid
Salix women Alice is important because
it's the most widely grown species of
Salix in biomass in Europe and so a lot
of the studies in this system have been
conducted using Salix women Alice on
European species of Malaya so all of
these individuals have been sequenced
using GPS and so I put together this PCA
of those eight families so you can kind
of see the common parents line four one
nine four six or kind of splitting the
families where I'm doing it again see
none 401 and nine 406 are kind of
splitting the two families up where when
we look at PC one we can see that these
two families here are the Salix of women
Alice that I just mentioned where this
one is sale excu densest so PC one is
really separating these families
phylogenetically so these three are in
the section femen where the families on
the other side of the PCA are from the
section helix so they're more related
where PC two is doing the work of
separating out each family so you can
see we have this family here with the f1
kind of lying somewhere in the middle as
we would expect it to do so now that we
have our GPS data if I want to map GTL I
need to construct maps for everything so
I put together this general pipeline of
the way that I handled that GPS data so
I use tassel GPS to call variants which
depending on the family resulted between
three and five hundred thousand markers
in each family these were then passed
into the tassel GUI and I filtered for
up to 80% presence which really cut down
those number of markers they were then
subset in our four back cross markers so
we then instead of dealing with one
population now we're dealing with two
separate maps for each one for each
parent based on the parental genotype
and then I used a combination of our
QTL and a s map to do some additional
filtering and for determining linkage
groups and establishing the marker order
and so each map at the end of this
process has between one and three
thousand markers so we have 16 maps in
total two for each of the families so
again now that we've got the maps this
makes it sound so easy now they've got
the maps we need the phenotype data to
really kind of bring it together
unfortunately leaf rust has not been
very cooperative with me in this study
so in the years 2016 and 2018 we had
negligible to no leaf rust presence in
the field at all
so we're really hoping 2019 we can
actually get a good survey but the one
that we were able to do 2017 in reality
is a mild rest year but we can still
there's still things to learn from this
and I should mention that all of these
families are planted up at Cornell
Agrotech in Geneva there's four
replications it's about four thousand
plots for all families together and so
they've all been surveyed so now that
I've had this plot up for a little while
let me try and explain it a little bit
so the two purple bars are the common
parents so there's nine for a six here a
nine 4:01 the vertical line in the
middle delineates the families that are
using that common female or common male
parents so as you look at each f1 which
are these larger boxes the female is
always on the left of the f1 with the
male next to it so get the comment the
female male f f1 male f1 male and it
switches on the other side each dot
represents a genotypic mean to kind of
give you an idea even though the mean is
here we still have a wide range of leaf
rust severity through these populations
so when I finally got this figure worked
out one of the first things that jumped
out to me is how each family kind of has
its own story with leaf rest so in the
case of this family here
the 4:07 family we can see that the mean
of the f1 is kind of between the parents
which is what we think more of as an
additive model with the between the two
parents but if we look at 4:43 on the
end there seems to be a breakdown in
resistance and that's common throughout
some of the other families as well so
even though like I said even though this
was a mild year
we're still getting story about leaf
rust with each of these separate
families so it's important to kind of
think of them as a population but also
as an individual families as we kind of
think about the results that we find so
now that I've got the maps constructed
and a phenotype data I actually was able
to identify a few QTL and so I just
pulled one out so I could show you so
this is a map from one of the such a
winces families it's a map of the female
common parent that I put together and we
were able to find a QTL on chromosome 7
so you can see this kind of
National Monument shaped GTL here has
this nice peak here which actually maybe
a little bit lucky is a marker it's an
actual marker and so pulling that out
looking at the allele effects you can
see that the anything homozygous at that
marker there is still a rating here but
a lot of them are at zero and it's very
mild whereas anything heterozygous at
that low sigh has a higher higher
phenotype suggesting maybe partial it's
conferring may be partial resistance at
that so going forward with these maps I
really want to as I said a few times
each family kind of has its own
personality and so I want to go through
each of the genetic maps and kind of
address some of the eccentricities there
before I finalized them and content with
with what their with their status once
that's done I'll be able to go through
and finalize the list of leaf rescue TL
but I was able to find and naturally
I've been applying I've been going
through those fields or a lot of
separate traits and so like I want to
use those traits as well and I would
also like to try a way to analyze all
eight families together I'm kind of
bouncing around with that but I want to
make sure I get these maps done before I
move on so with that in mind I'd like to
thank everyone for coming and I also
like to thank everyone at the Larry
smart lab with a special shout out to
Rebecca
Lauren Jane and Dawn who are our
technicians
it's pretty much everyone here knows the
lab would fall apart without them so
we're just really grateful for them and
also Holly and chase from the Chris
smart lab so I like to thank everyone
again and I can take questions
[Applause]
any here's what you don't have roster
this actually don't have bus could you
somehow visually a not so the question
was and use that we don't have rest can
we artificially inoculate some of the
right yeah so I know that that has been
done so I mentioned at row well he'll
he's kind of my partner in crime and
Plant Pathology and Chris smart slab so
he has done some work with different
isolates of rest in these different
families but as far as well my work is
done it's really important that we can
get filled so the question was are we
after complete resistance or with some
partial resistance be enough and
honestly as I said when you're dealing
with a mixture planting it's really best
to have different levels of resistance
because obviously you don't want to
encourage kind of that selection you
kind of want to let it you almost want
to let it have something so that it's
there's a lot of selection pressure so
in terms of if we care about absolute or
partial I think I'm open to whatever I
can find it's really about kind of
characterizing what we have so the
question is what if we know about the
race structure with in Milan's Rafi so
there is a lot of work on that I know
Chris smarts lab has done some work on
that but definitely compared to We Trust
we don't know very much about so a lot
of what we've been able to find is as
different species of will obviously
respond
differently to the different races so we
know that we can go into a field in any
given year we're probably gonna find
different races within a single field
but I don't know if it's really been
characterized this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu